sports director chris matthews starts
our team coverage tonight from t-mobile
arena chris
well thank you very much guys i'll tell
you what all three of those wins have
come from behind by the vegas golden
knights so they're playing
really good hockey right now we'll see
what happens in game six the winner of
this right now they have about a 79
percent chance of winning this series
at one time when they were trying to
know two they were down
about 82 percent a chance of losing this
series so they've absolutely
completely flipped the numbers here a
chance to close out the avalanche here
tonight
hey joining us now is derek clinton
former golden knight and
uh channel 8 hockey expert every monday
we uh love having you on derek
talk about this big game six a chance to
close it out yeah it's huge
you know you don't want to go back up to
colorado it's a tough building to play
in and
this is one of the best so you want to
close it out in front of your home fans
and
you know it could be an extra day or two
off between
this and the next round too what are the
golden knights doing to shut down that
potent
colorado offense nathan mckinnon doesn't
have a point in three games
yeah i think you know stoney is his
defensive player he's always in the
right place right time
and you got stevenson that is probably
one of the few guys that can match
mckinnon's speed and
you know it's just a lot of fun to watch
they're not getting the points that they
normally get but they're doing a huge
job and a tremendous job with that
you know we talked about mark andre
fleury i think his goals against is like
1.8
or 1.88 or something he's doing a real
good job isn't he yeah he's keeping them
you know last game they go on that
i thought you know colorado kind of took
it to him a little bit in the first and
second period but uh
you know he gave up the one late in the
first and one more but he kept them
kept them within striking distance and
gave him a chance to win all right derek
i got to get a prediction from you here
game six in the fortress the two teams
uh
i gotta stick with my guns i gotta go
it's gonna be a tight game and an
overtime win for us
all right there you heard it from derek
england and of course we'll have more we
face off with derrick england each and
every monday
so hopefully we're talking about the
next series the semis thank you very
much derek i appreciate that
let's toss it now out onto toshiba plaza
and that is where john treach is hanging
out with those medieval maniacs
that's right chris as the players are
skating the fans are scurrying
to get inside t-mobile arena for puck
drop
the knights are on the ice and i tell
you what it's colorado on thin
ice as the golden knight fan since
history
and since being on the doorstep of
something really special as you can see
behind me fans are kind of anxious to
get in there as hopefully they'll delay
the
start just a few minutes for everyone to
get in there's still several
hundred people maybe even thousands of
people here and just about 10 minutes
ago there were about 5 000 people
in toshiba plaza and i have to admit it
was the most i've seen since
the shark series in 2019 in one place
it was quite a scythe i mean there were
medieval maniacs as far as the eye could
see
and now of course they are on the
doorstep of the fortress
and history game six and we everybody
that we talked to
there's a nervousness but there's also a
confidence that we didn't see
last week so you have to appreciate that
this knowledgeable hockey fan base
senses that this team can clinch tonight
so we'll continue to have updates
throughout the six o'clock show
and again tonight at 11. reporting live
john treach 8 sports now